you know when people pass we tend to  sanctify them once they're gone but with  Bonnie tegel there just aren't enough  superlatives to describe the energy the  sweetness the spirit the kindness that  this woman has she was the best medicine  ever because she always lit up whenever  she saw you and you know you always felt  better about yourself for being around  her she just made you feel well she just  made you feel okay and it didn't matter  whether it was in front of the camera or  behind the scenes it just didn't matter  in a business that's full of phony she  was a rare gym full of authenticity and  integrity she never had an agenda she  never did anything for effect God truly  broke the mold when he made her in this  world there are givers and there are  takers and bonnie was the giver of all  givers so Bonnie if you're listening you  will be missed but trust me girl you  will never ever be forgot